large insurance companies in our country
mr. Mark Bertolini received a golden
parachute worth nearly 500 million
dollars after his company merged with
CVS health 34 million Americans have no
health insurance many more are
underinsured and one insurance company
executive pockets almost 500 million
dollars for a merger which will only
drive health care cost higher please do
not tell us that this is a rational
health care system it is not
you
able to afford the prescription drugs he
or she needs we should not tolerate a
system which allows the top ten drug
companies to make 69 billion dollars in
profits last year while at the same time
and this is really unbelievable one out
of five Americans who get a prescription
from their doctor cannot even afford to
fill that prescription how crazy is that
and then the drug companies ending up
end up charging us by far the highest
prices in the world for the medicine
that we need we should not tolerate a
system that allows the former CEO of
Gilead to become a billionaire by
charging $1,000 a pill for a hepatitis C
drug called sovaldi $1,000 a pill so
that he could become a billionaire let
us make no mistake about and this is a
point that I'll be making over and over
again not here today but all over the
country
and that what we are involved in is not
just healthcare legislation we are
involved in a great struggle not unlike
to be honest with you the struggles of
the labor movement the struggles of the
civil rights movement struggles of the
women's movement struggles of the gay
community struggles of the environmental
movement this is what we are involved
this is not just an idea that Kirsten or
Jeff Ryan if you are the sort of this is
a struggle for the heart and soul of who
we are as American people and this
struggle will be opposed let us be clear
about it by some of the most powerful
forces in the United States entities
that have on limited amounts of money to
throw against us the insurance companies
the drug companies and everyone who
profits off the current system will
spend many many hundreds of millions of
dollars to defeat us they will run
endless 30-second television ads telling
us telling you all how terrible we are
they'll be putting full-page magazine
ads or magazines all over this country
and they'll have misleading studies to
frighten the American people about
Medicare for all which is exactly as you
may recall what happened before before
the passage of Medicare in the 1960s and
the reason that we have a health care
system which is dysfunctional is fairly
obvious it is not just to huge profits
in the insurance industry and the
pharmaceutical industry but it is the
incredible waste and bureaucracy
developed by many thousands of
healthcare plans today hospitals and
doctors must deal with patients who have
different deductibles different
co-payments different networks of
coverage and different coverages
for pharmaceuticals or no insurance at
all all of this is not only driving
doctors and nurses and hospital
administrators to distraction but it is
wasting up to 500 billion dollars a year
all of that bureaucracy all of that
administration is wasting enormous sums
of money in my view and I think I speak
for everybody up here the American
people are increasingly clear they want
a health care system that guarantees
health care to all Americans as a right
they want a health care system which
will lower health care costs and save
them money they want a health care
system which will guarantee them freedom
of choice in terms of the doctor or
hospital they go to they want a health
care system which will substantially
lower the cost of prescription drugs
they want a healthcare system which will
finally give senior citizens the
benefits they need for dental care for
hearing aids and for eyeglasses
[Applause]
brothers and sisters in other words the
American people wants and we are going
to deliver a medicare-for-all
single-payer system thank you and now
let me introduce somebody who has been
fighting for health care for all from
New York State Kirsten Gillibrand
Kirsten
thank you for everybody so let me talk
about the problem no matter where I've
been in my state around this country the
number one issue on every person's mind
is access to affordable health care
number one issue and with President
Trump constantly undermining the work we
did in the Affordable Care Act people
are really afraid they're afraid that
they have a pre-existing condition and
nobody will cover them they're afraid
that their child has a disease or an
illness and they won't be able to get
the medicines they need they're afraid
that if they actually have to pay for
the medicine that they need to survive
they will go bankrupt doing it it is
unconscionable that people in America
don't know if they will survive a
disease or healthcare illness or
something this can affect their lives or
their family lives because of the greed
and corruption in Washington that
decides everything but that's the truth
they're afraid and
you
boy if he'll survive he doesn't know if
his life will be in front of him because
if his access is taken away he just
doesn't know and this is something that
is so vital to humanity health care must
be a right not a privilege because it is
what we believe it's what our country
needs this has to become the next social
safety net it has to become something
that is there for you no matter what no
matter if you can afford it
no matter where you live no matter what
so we have to take on the problem now
Bernie mentioned the problem the problem
is greed and corruption the problem is
how everything works here in washing do
you know why Medicare can't buy in bulk
to get the cheapest prices well it was a
sweetheart deal made by Congress and the
drug companies in the dead of night when
we passed Medicare Part D under george w
bush that's how laws are written the
special interests the most powerful
people with endless supplies of money
they get to do whatever they want
whenever they want it so this is a
moment when we have to decide what kind
of country are we going to be and this
is a decision that every single one of
us has to make now it is something that
cannot be put off it cannot be delayed
we have to say will we fight for this
democracy will we take back this
democracy and the way you do it the way
you do it is you get off the couch you
stop throwing things at the TV and you
start marching you start marching you
start protesting you start campaigning
against members of Congress senators and
presidents that don't share this human
right this value that we share you put
your whole life and your whole body into
the breach because if you don't we will
not prevail it is up to us and so we got
to get money out of politics we got to
have publicly funded elections we got to
actually restore voting rights we got to
make sure these legislators around the
country can't take away our right to
vote
we need everything to make our democracy
ours automatic voter registration
getting election day off making sure
people can vote by mail having those
paper receipts all of it so this is what
we're up against and the way to get
there is really simple and I'm gonna
tell you how we're gonna pass Medicare
for all and how we're actually gonna
make it a reality the part of the bill
that senator Sanders and I worked on
together the part I got to write is the
transition phase and let me be really
clear about why this gets us to medicare
for all single-payer if you let
Americans decide today that you can buy
into Medicare for a small percentage of
your income for the lowest wage worker
it's 2% for the highest wage worker it's
5% and you get to buy in no matter what
you are creating a not-for-profit public
option that is good high-quality health
care now I dare I dare any insurance
company to just try to compete they
won't the insurance industry wants to
make money they are a for-profit
industry their goals are not aligned
with ours that's why we could never get
where we wanted to go with universal
coverage building it on top of a
for-profit industry because they must
maintain corporate profits they must
maintain shareholder value Bernie just
gave us an example of somebody who got a
five hundred billion dollar golden
parachute the money the greed the
corruption that surrounds our health
care system today is what is in the way
it is why it is not possible so let's
let competition work it's magic let's
actually let have greater competition
say anybody combined I promise you I
would on the first day if I could buy in
at four percent of my income yeah that
would be great and I get all the
coverage I needed I would get the
medicines I need I would get everything
and if you fix Medicare in this process
making sure you have more transparency
making sure that providers are
reimbursed the right rate for the things
they're providing making sure health
care becomes a continuum of care places
like the Mayo Clinic they know how to do
this you lower cost you get economies of
scale you get people into preventive
care that's how you bend the cost curve
and if you provide that transition
that transition period I promise you
you're gonna get to medicare-for-all as
a single payer because the American
people are going to choose it I ran on
this idea in 2006 in a two-to-one
Republican district do you hear what I'm
saying
I ran on this in a two-to-one Republican
district red red red not only did I win
but I got re-elected by a twenty four
point margin that is how you get to
Medicare for all if we take this
democracy back if we fight with our
voices with our views with our hearts
and our souls we will prevail thank you
Kirsten
Jeff Merkley has been a fight up for
Medicare for all for many years just
thank you so much so how about a little
appreciation for those 60 plus
organizations grassroots organizations
are going to fight to make this happen
here to be nice
so I have some some questions for you
all should health care be about profits
or people are you angry and frustrated
with the system with enormous complexity
are you frustrated by the enormous price
gouging in the medical drug industry are
you ready for a simple seamless Medicare
for all plan for all of America well I'm
so glad to hear it because I can tell
you this as I go around all of my town
halls in Oregon and I have 36 counties
22 very red counties to build on what
Kirsten was saying they are frustrated
with the complexity in America you earn
a little bit more money you're kicked
off of the Oregon Health Plan that is
Medicaid and then what do you do you
have an employer says now I'm not going
to cover your children how do you get
your children covered another employer
says I'm not going to cover your spouse
how do your spouse get covered you're
always in transition employer changes
health care plans and now you have to
get a different doctor it's the most
complicated system well how about a
simple seamless plan for all Americans
and then we look at the enormous cost of
it we pay twice as much and get less
health outcomes for Americans how about
we pay less than other countries get
more outcomes and I'd stand out as I
said well I hear people come into my
town halls and say I have a simple
inhaler I pay a hundred dollars here it
costs $4.00 in Europe why is that I have
a cholesterol drug it cost five times in
America what it cost overseas why is
that I have a diabetes drug that costs
ten times as much even though insulin
has been around forever why is that
it's the profit in the medical drug
system that's why we need to have a plan
where we negotiate the price of drugs
will we get a better deal than that's
the world you know we spend a lot more
on research here in America than the
Canadians do the Europeans do the
Japanese do shouldn't we get the best
deal in the world not the worst deal in
the world so now we have to make it
happen and we're up against this
enormous enormous amount of money that's
going to try to mislead people they're
going to use the gerrymandering and the
voter suppression and the dark money our
Supreme Court's been right at the center
of this dysfunction this corruption of
our constitutional we the people vision
you know I love those first three words
of our Constitution
I love Jefferson talking about
distributed power he says the only way
he called it equal voice he said the
only way you get laws reflect the will
of the people is to have distributed
power not concentrated but here it's a
Supreme Court concentrating power
through citizens united and then voter
suppression we saw it in every form in
every form on November 6 trying to take
away the vote from poor communities and
and communities minority communities and
from college communities taking it away
from Native American reservations how
about we believe in voter empowerment
not voter suppression so one of the
pieces we have to do to win this fight
we have to pass the for the people act
that will take on gerrymandering and
voter suppression and dark money and
restore the vision of our Constitution
so we're going to do it together
enormous outside force inside force
thank you for being in the battle we
need every American
off the couch and on the battlefield god
bless you all thank you Jeff now we're
gonna hear from some very special guests
who are involved in this struggle not
only politically but in their work every
single day who understand what a
dysfunctional health care system means
for the patients that they deal with
let's begin with Ron Elsa Goodell who is
a registered nurse in the cardiac
procedures lab at Washington Hospital
Center here in DC and she is a member of
National Nurses United we know something
good morning my name is Ron Elsa Cordell
I'm a cardiac registered nurse I work at
a hospital center here in the district
and I'm a proud member of National
Nurses United becoming a registered
nurse was one of the most important
decisions in my life because it gave me
the privilege of being able to provide a
healing hand to my patients that are
hurting are in pain and that are their
most vulnerable but it's becoming harder
every day to provide the care my
patients need I recently had a patient
who had been unemployed for nine months
his health insurance had been tied to
his employment
therefore he lost his health insurance
when he lost his job as a result he
could not afford to get care and
medications he needed for his high blood
pressure and diabetes by the time he got
a new job and had health insurance he
had because his heart had begun to fail
as a result this patient is experiencing
new onset heart failure that would have
been presented if he had gotten the care
he needed I recently had another patient
with a serious heart problem this
patient had suffered an earlier heart
attack brought on by severe stress when
she presented at the hospital of
concerning symptoms the doctor doctor
recommended that we take a CT scan to
assess changes in her heart health he
did not want to do a heart
catheterization a more invasive
procedure unless the CT scan showed that
it was Ness
sorry I took the patient down to get her
CT scan in the middle of the procedure
we received a call telling us that we
did not have authorization to conduct
this procedure because insurance company
would not pay for it so in the middle of
the CT scan we had to stop the procedure
and take the patient off the table
insurance company should not be
overruling the decisions of medical
professionals they should not have the
authority to prevent patients from
getting the care that they need
Thank You senator Sanders for continuing
to take a stand that health care is a
human right guaranteed for every man
woman and child every day at hospitals
and clinics around this country bedside
nurses care for patients who have
delayed care because of lack of
insurance or because of high deductibles
and co-pays we need to take insurance
companies out of the equation and an act
a single-payer medicare-for-all system
[Applause]
to me and other registered nurses across
the country it is immoral that anyone
profits them and not the person's needs
for health care and it's disgusting to
me that profit can come from denying
care the the way to stop this is by
passing medicare-for-all single-payer
legislation and I'm here to tell you
that nurses across the country are going
to fight for it thank you
thank you for Nelson and I will hear
from Nicola Blanc who is a disability
rights advocate who works at the
development disabilities Administration
good afternoon everyone my name is
Nicola Blanc I live in Silver Spring I'm
originally from Vermont I'm on the
autism spectrum I'm glad to be here to
thank senator Sanders for including home
and community-based services long-term
care and the new version of the Medicare
for all bill now now it can be called a
bill that is truly for all nothing about
me without me during the healthcare
fight in 2017 I stood in amazement at
every rally event hearing and protests
where people with disabilities like me
who were willing to put their bodies on
the line scream and shout and share
their stories all because our health
care and freedom was at risk what was
most at risk and what scared us all the
most was the loss of those home and
community-based services like many
people with disabilities I need help
with things like budgeting dealing with
benefit chaos with Social Security for
example in finding dental care something
that Marilyn for the last few years
doesn't cover for adults they just
started a pilot for 800 which will take
place supposedly in July for people who
are dually eligible but still 800
dollars is not enough most people with
disabilities have higher dental care
cost HCBS services helped with you know
dealing with the system I was so excited
when I read the Medicare for all in 2019
Sanders bill includes long-term services
and supports as a benefit this bill will
support people living at the community
where we all belong when this bill
becomes law almost 1 million people with
this one waiting list for HCBS services
will have access to them because it is
for all
when I moved to Maryland the services
that I had in Vermont that allowed me to
be successful as a working advocate did
not move with me I had to reapply
through Maryland system which the system
is based on institutionalization IQ we
need a system that's you know based on
function no more IQ no more being at
risk of institutionalization and a
system that conserved the whole spectrum
regardless of severity
I had to reapply through the Maryland's
that this means people like me who want
to move for work for work can get the
services and have them come with us just
like money follows the person it moves
the money out of the institution same
here almost and I am so excited that
this now would include dental services
over the past year I got a dental
consultation and discovered I need five
to eight grand worth in dental work and
I have gum disease in Maryland however
there's an 800 cap soon to be
implemented come July however most of us
need more than that I am so honored to
be here and thank senator Sanders for
interment introducing a bill that is for
all and will help people with disability
healthy happy and productive people with
idd are medically underserved population
and often have worse health outcomes and
studies show that people who get HCBS
services are healthier than those who
don't
I call I call on Congress to work in a
bipartisan fashion and make long-term
care accessible for all people with
autism and other disabilities
community-based long-term services is
something that affects everyone
regardless of political party it is a
non partisan issue I call on Congress to
get Medicare for all passed in a
bipartisan fashion now long term care is
a human right and face reality if we all
live long enough we'll all join the
disability Club you're all welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I'd like to introduce dr. Perry
Tsai who is a physician and the national
president of the American Medical
Student Association from jigna hello
everyone again my name is Perry saw in
the national president am so the
American Medical Student Association I
recently graduated with my MD PhD from
the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill School of Medicine I am
representing hear the voice of campuses
27,000 members this is the voice of
27,000 physicians in training an
independent voice for the future of
Medicine and with that voice
we as future physicians are here to say
that we want Medicare for all
as medical students we all start out
with this dream a dream of becoming
doctors physicians true healers for our
patients and our communities we signed
up for hours of studying months of
clinical rotations years of residency
training all to achieve the stream and
what do we learn in all of this training
we learned how to do procedures what
drugs to use what clinical decisions to
consider we learned how to think
critically ask questions how to diagnose
a problem and tackle it we learned all
of these things in order become a
physician who cares for our patients our
families and our communities but what
else do we learn for every procedure we
perform we've also seen the exasperation
flash across a doctors eyes as they
field another call from the insurance
company for every drug we memorize
you've also watched farm executives
drive up the price of medicines such
that our patients can't even get them
for every clinical recommendation we
make we've also sat quietly with a
patient who's choosing to leave the
hospital or skip their medication
because they don't want to strap their
family with the bill for everything that
we learn on our way to becoming
physicians who care for patients we find
one more thing that's going to prevent
us from caring for our patients for
every medical student that's burning
bright with passion there's a future
physician who's burning out from the
administrative burdens the loss of
connection with their patients the
feeling of powerlessness generated by a
system that values profits over people
as our country faces a looming physician
shortage we're finding more and more
reasons
just stay away our dream is turning into
a nightmare and we will not stand for it
so we're thinking critically we're
asking questions why is it like this why
does it have to be this way we're
diagnosing the problem we're looking for
solutions the root causes that in our
country healthcare is controlled by
insurance companies pharmaceutical
companies who value profit instead of
health care senator Sanders here is
offering a real solution today in
Medicare for all Medicare for all means
our patients will all have health
insurance regardless of their employment
status and have access to the health
care they need Medicare for all means
that physicians can spend more time with
their patients and less time dealing
with insurance companies Medicare for
all means that pharmaceutical companies
will have to negotiate to make drugs
affordable for everybody and ultimately
medicare for all is about justice so
many of our problems that we have in the
United States racial inequality economic
inequality all of these either start
from or they lead to health care
inequality Medicare for all is a step
towards health care dresses is a step
towards economic justice is a step
towards racial justice we at AMSA
believe that health care is a human
right and we at AMSA envision a more
just world where we can fulfill our
dreams to become physicians providing
that health care that's why we need
health care for all that's why we need
Medicare for all thank you
deborah berger is a registered nurse and
she is co-president of the National
Nurses Union Deborah good so I am Debra
Berger a registered nurse and president
of National Nurses United the largest
union and professional association of
registered nurses in the United States
the introduction of senator Sanders
Medicare for all Act is a clear sign
that guaranteed care real health care
for every resident of this country not
just insurance that tens of millions of
people can't afford is coming Thank You
senator Sanders for your lifelong
commitment and leadership on winning
Medicare for all and health security for
our families and our community and I
want to thank the entire Senate
co-sponsors of this vital legislation
this a and this bill have a special
meaning to nurses of America and Nu
members have worked for decades to
achieve fundamental transformation of
our health care system one based on
patient need not ability to pay on
caring and healing not on profiteering
of sickness nurses see the pain and
suffering of our patients every single
day we care for patients abandoned by a
cruel system that limits and denies
their access to health care we see
patients and families who are forced to
make unconscionable decisions that no
one no one should have to make whether
they get treatment and care they need or
pay for their rent or mortgage bill or
food for their children that's the real
America we nurses see
the America where one third of all go
fund me accounts are for medical bills
that's outrageous
last year alone Americans had to borrow
88 billion dollars to pay for health
care that's not something that should
ever happen in our America we can no
longer accept a system that treats
people as commodities enriching private
wealth rather than public health we are
going to change that other countries
with sane humane health care systems
such as proposed in the Medicare for All
Act have demonstrated there is an
alternative the u.s. spends almost 3
times the average of other
industrialized countries on health care
yet we fall far behind on critical areas
such as life expectancy maternal and
infant mortality deaths from preventable
diseases or complications and
disparities based on race gender and
income it's going to be up to all of us
to make Medicare for all a reality and
nu is working with nurses and health
care activists every day talking to
voters across the country we have
organized tens of thousands of
volunteers who are making phone calls
knocking on doors and going out into
their neighborhoods and communities they
and we are working to build a grassroots
movement that will pass Medicare for all
[Music]
no matter how much the insurance
companies are the pharmaceuticals stand
in our way
we are going to win Medicare for just as
it took millions to abolish slavery to
win the vote for women to ban child
labor and to end racial segregation laws
make no mistake we are going to win this
- thank you all and last but not least I
want to introduce somebody who's been
fighting for Medicare for all four years
Senator Richard Blumenthal of
Connecticut well I I think I am the last
and the least and I say that without any
false modesty because following such
eloquence from a nurse and a doctor is
even better than following Bernie
Sanders but I was proud to stand with
Bernie Sanders when he introduced this
measure I was proud to stand with my
Senate colleagues and I am prouder than
ever today to stand with you this is
what America looks like the memo to
Donald Trump this is our future Medicare
for all I just came from a hearing in
the Judiciary Committee for the nominee
for second-in-command in the United
States Department of Justice which is
arguing in court right now that the
Affordable Care Act should be decimated
destroyed abandoned so we are here to
represent America and the needs of
America now I know because I have heard
it from countless other doctors and
insurance companies and pharmaceutical
companies it will never work it's
impractical
it's unrealistic it's a dream and
they're right medicare-for-all is a
dream it's called the American dream the
American Dream is real for many
Americans who can afford high-priced
health insurance and high-priced
pharmaceutical drugs and high-priced
doctor care but even with the great
progress we've made 34 million Americans
still are uninsured the debt as you just
heard that Americans incur every year is
88 billion dollars it drives them into
bankruptcy medical debt is the biggest
cause of bankruptcy in this country
which means everybody loses and the fear
of bankruptcy causes people to walk out
of pharmacies without the medicine they
need to make themselves better and to
enable them to come to the workplace and
do good stuff for all of us that we need
for a thriving economy you know I think
it was Bruce Springsteen who said nobody
wins unless we all win nobody wins
unless we all win on health care that
ought to be our motto in the United
States of America that's the American
dream that's our dream we're gonna make
it happen
Medicare for all is our future and we
have to make it our present I want to
thank all of you for being here today
and giving us the hope and inspiration
to keep fighting because we're gonna
keep fighting thank you so much
okay I think you heard from everybody
and the message is the same together
from coast to coast we're gonna roll up
our sleeves we're gonna take on the
insurance companies we're gonna take on
the drug companies and we are going to
fulfill as senator Blumenthal said the
American dream and the dream is that
every American no matter what your
income no matter where you live is
entitled to health care as a human right
not a privilege thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]